now in 2021 uh scotland is a
sad and uh angry uh and
and frightened place with you know with
lots of people full of
dismay and and apprehension about what
the future must hold
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantin kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people and a
fascinating guest we have
for you today he's returning to the show
for the second time
scottish historian tv presenter neil
oliver welcome back to trigonometry
oh thank you very much for having me
gents it's good to see you both
it's good to see you and to have you
back listen since we last spoke
we talked mainly about history and the
pandemic and things like that but uh
there's been a lot going on in your
country in scotland i lived there for
many years
and i have no idea what's going on and
we were just looking at it going we need
someone to explain it to us and here you
are
oh my goodness well in the beginning the
earth cooled
and part of it for me i would say right
right from the top you know
you say my country of scotland and of
course i was born and i live in scotland
but
um the whole thing for me is is
underwritten by the fact that my
country is britain um that is
and that's not or it never used to be a
political statement uh
i was born well 54 years ago uh
and just quietly without any particular
reason by osmosis or whatever absorbed
an understanding that i was british born
in britain
uh and it's it's very important to me
that that situation prevails
um apart from anything else i'm often
characterized
as being anti scottish independence
in truth i'm not actually anti-anything
first and foremost i am just for
the united kingdom of britain because
that's where i was born
and that nationality is my is part of my
identity
and i simply refuse to have any group of
politicians
here today gone tomorrow strip me of
what i understand to be my
nationality and replace it with another
uh without my consent uh and so
yes there's a great deal happening up
here
uh on account of the the scottish
government
in the scottish parliament at uh at
hollywood
uh and i am i am confused and
dismayed by by a lot of it but but my
stance isn't always has been that i am
i am for britain that's that's being
british is what i understand about
myself
to share neil uh what we like to do here
trigonometry start the interview by
asking a slightly insensitive question
uh to to get the guests nice and warmed
up and so we've managed to do that but
it seems like uh you guys are having
some sort of like live-action macbeth
reenactment
in scotland uh so can you tell us more
about what's happening there
i i suspect you're probably referring to
the um
what is generally known as the alex
salmond inquiry
which has yes it's been uh it's been a
shakespearean
uh drama uh played across what feels
like years
um and it has well you know it has it
has
run its course in terms of the salmon
inquiry has run its course uh and but
having said that
it remains it remains unclear exactly
what it decided
uh the the inquiry's own committee
seemed to decide that the first minister
had misled
parliament but then there's another
another judgment came in from a from an
from an independent
in another independent inquiry that that
said differently
so exactly what has been decided
at the end of the the months years of
wranglings around
of what alex salmond was first of all
alleged to have done then his name was
cleared in court and then this whole
inquiry into the way in which he was
investigated by government has run
on and on and on it has taken on layers
of byzantine complexity
i think anyone outside of scotland
would struggle would struggle to have
followed
the twists and turns of it you know
you'd really you'd really have to be an
obsessive
you'd really have to be invested in the
whole uh the whole
imbroglio to keep up with it um
and i i don't i don't claim to have
followed every twist and turn what
what i take away from it though is the
extent to which
the this scottish government has
uh has chosen secrecy over openness
that has just been from the beginning
there was there were efforts made and
a concerted attempt to keep as much as
possible under wraps
and and this from a government that had
said all along or said in the past that
it was always going to be open
always going to be open with the people
of scotland that had nothing to hide
that everything would be there to be
looked at and discussed the first
minister said exactly that that she
intended to
um cooperate with the inquiry completely
and fully and that nothing would be off
limits
and yet it has just been a culture of
secrecy and obfuscation
and uh you know hiding behind legalities
uh legal minutiae and there has just
been this constant attempt to keep as
much information it would appear as
possible
away from the the general public
certainly from the scottish public
that's what i have taken away from it
and that is what dismays me
uh that we live that we're living with a
government that is
so secretive about how it goes about its
business
and neil do you think that this has
irreparably damaged sturgeon's
uh premiership oh gosh
uh no uh i i think the
i think she is in um
what she continues to be i would say in
a in a fairly unassailable
position uh the the scottish national
party
is is so strong uh has taken such
uh control over so much in scotland the
crown office which is the
which is the scottish equivalent of the
cps the crown prosecution service
uh you know has been working in concert
with the scottish government
uh therefore you cannot say with any
confidence in fact you can't say at all
that there's separation of powers
in scotland you know the whole one of
the principles of
western liberal democracy and
governments thereof is that the
legislative and the executor and the
judiciary
are separate from one another that's not
the case in scotland there's no
second chamber in the scottish
parliament no house of lords or its
equivalent
uh and the the the doings the business
of government is supposed to be
scrutinized by committees
and it was said long ago uh when those
when the
when the devolution settlement was was
put in place that the
the the committees would have all the
teeth they needed uh properly and
effectively to hold
the government's account but the salmon
inquiry has absolutely
laid bare the fact that the scottish
parliament cannot hold
the scottish government to account
as far as it would appear the the
scotland act
and the devolution settlement uh which
was the product of the scotland act is
not fit for purpose
uh and it's i i find it i find it
harrowing i i feel that we live in
something that's nudging towards a
failed state a a banana republic where
bananas don't grow
we'll wait for global warming now then
we'll see bananas in scotland
uh but but neil you make it sound
as if scotland is in some kind of
political crisis which
from the outside no one would you know
it seems that you know sturgeon has had
a very good war
in terms of the you know the coronavirus
is it really that bad up there
uh well it depends what side of the line
you're standing on
i i'm sure um those who support the
scottish government and those who
support the scottish national party will
be
you know will be will be very happy with
what has happened but
scotland is absolutely a country that's
split
down the middle uh 14 years of
the scottish national party has seen to
that scotland is a divided place
the scotland that i grew up in well it's
it's unrecognizable
now uh the atmosphere is one of
bitterness
constant anger division uh
clanishness uh uh feelings of being
on you know of two fundamentally two
tribes
you know being on the barricades hurling
whatever ammunition they can
at one another and there's a feeling
that that situation just becomes
ever more ever more entrenched you know
you say that
scotland had a good uh or the scottish
government had a good
covert well they didn't the the the
deaths such as they're being tallied are
obviously everything's on a smaller
scale in scotland we've only got five
million of a population compared to
you know 60 odd million in england or in
the rest of the uk
so the numbers are always smaller but
examined proportionally
our death tolls have been the same the
situation in the care homes was
desperate
more people died proportionally in the
care homes in scotland than did
so in the rest of the uk and when i last
looked at the figures and i don't look
at them on a daily basis but we seemed
to be
uh you know one of the worst places uh
in the uk or the worst place in the uk
in terms of covered
infections or cases or however there's
however the counting and
and categorizing it today or this or
this morning
and so we haven't had a good covert
we've had the same covert as everybody
else
in the uk we've because of devolution uh
the first minister here nicola sturgeon
has been able to
plow her own furrow up to next up to up
to a point or to an extent and so
there have been different dates about
when we would open this or close that
and
you know if you were allowed six people
we might be allowed eight or
you know there's been variations almost
just for the sake of variation but
uh as a as a place to be as a place to
live
now in 2021 uh scotland is a
sad and uh angry uh and
and frightened place with you know with
lots of people full of
dismay and and apprehension about what
the future must hold
that broadcast was brought to you by the
scottish tourist information board there
near well done
uh but it's obviously a difficult time
uh and you feel very strongly about the
independence issue and i actually wanted
to ask you
is there anything beyond independence
itself that underpins that divide
uh is it is there a religious or ethnic
or sort of political like what is the
divide
about or is it purely about do you want
scotland to be
independent of the united kingdom that
is the that's the fracture
that's the fault line i suppose along
which
the country has most obviously split
uh you know scotland like anywhere i
mean it's not unique to scotland but
it's a place
of many tribes if you like uh you know
it's it's difficult to talk of one
scotland
uh historically it was a place of of
clans
a place of tribes you know going back
further beyond before the time of of the
clans
and as you travel through what is a
relatively small place
there's a great variety in the
population of scotland the north is very
different from the south
the east is very different from the west
yes there has of course
a courtesy of sectarianism between
catholic and protestants there's always
been a religious
element to to certain unhappinesses
in in scotland uh but you know the
people of
orkney and shetland for example have
always
walked a different road than the rest of
scotland the people of the borders
are very different from the people in
the north east
or in the northwest the islands out to
the west the western isles it's a
different culture
a different a different group out there
it's you know there's always been a a
kind of a
a gallic a garlic dominance out in the
western isles or
or into the west there's been always
been pockets of garlic culture
so scotland is an enormously varied
place
which makes it very difficult when you
start talking about one scotland
at the last referendum in 2014
uh the the result was 45 55
55 of those voting favoring
remaining in the united kingdom but it's
definitely worth pointing out that of 32
local authorities in scotland
28 opted for remaining part of the
united
kingdom and only four only four local
authorities out of 32
uh had a majority in favor of of leaving
the union
and that's very significant you know the
heartland of of the independence vote
has always been glasgow eastern barton
uh dundee you know that's always been
the that's always been where the
hardcore of of independence has been
down in the southwest of scotland over
in the borders the northeast the
northwest
not so uh so it's a very um it's a
but that's that those kind of those kind
of local divisions
differences in local communities they're
always there they're in every country
it's the same in england
same in wales same in ireland there's
great differences
but the fundamental fracture across
which that has broken scotland's back
is the issue of independence and
there's a terrible sense of uh
hopelessness about it really
but i believe that that split is isn't
always was
roughly 50 50. depending on what day of
the week or what year
you wanted to take a a referendum hold a
referendum or take a straw poll
it would drift slightly either way but
it's more or less half and half
half the country in favor of one half
the country in favor the other
which means that whatever happens if
there was a referendum tomorrow
that came down in slightly in favor of
independence you've still got half the
country unhappy
and that's very difficult uh for that's
that's a very difficult um foundation
upon which to build anything cohesive
i've always said it's a bit like if you
if you're trying to fly a light aircraft
you know we cessna or something and
you've got a dead elephant strapped to
one wing
it's going to be really difficult to fly
the thing because it's so
unbalanced and so if there is a
subsequent referendum or if there are
more
referenda in the years ahead i think it
will always split
roughly 50 50. so it's always going to
be a pirate victory
for whoever carries the day and i said
right back in
well before the 2014 referendum it's
probably a question better left
unasked because the answer's just going
to make everyone
unhappy and so it has done
now as an englishman i don't understand
what you're talking about with
referendums making people unhappy or
splitting the country we've got
i've got no idea what you're talking
about but it's very
interesting the points you make one of
the points that i wanted to make is
how much of the sort of anti-union
feeling has been exacerbated number one
by brexit
and number two by what 12 years now or
11 years now of conservative rule would
it be more palatable
to remain within the union if number one
we were still in the european union
and number two if we had a labour party
in charge that's you've just added
another layer of complexity and
incomprehensibility to the whole thing
there it's what i bring to the podcast
now
because i'll tell you why i'll tell you
why in in 2014 or in the run-up to that
that first that referendum on on the on
the scottish question
uh it was clear that uh where the scots
to
favor independence in 2014 it would have
taken
scotland out of the european union
so a vote for scottish independence in
2014
was a vote to leave the eu
it was inevitable if if scotland had
become the time to rejoin that was the
plan right
well yes you know
that's jam tomorrow that's something
that might happen
you know there's plenty of evidence up
front because of the
because of catalonia in the basques in
spain and france that
that you know the idea of allowing a
separatist country
back into the european union as far as a
country like spain was concerned might
have been a red rag to a bull
but anyway that but the point was this
the scottish national party that the
independence campaign was
was predicated upon if you vote for
independence you're voting to leave the
european union that's what would have
happened
yeah at some point down the line they
may or may not have been able to rejoin
the eu but it was and at the time they
would say well if that's it
that that's the way it has to be so it
was effectively a
you know a skexit it was a scotland
leaving the european union in 2014
that's what would have happened if
scotland had voted for independence
and then 2016 of course the the brexit
referendum
in the uk you know the the decision was
taken to to leave the european union
and at that point at that point only did
the
you know did the the the yes campaign or
or the scottish government
you know take up the cudgels based on
the fact that scotland was being
quotes ripped out of the european union
against its will well
the scottish government would have
ripped scotland out of the european
union
against its will if they had got
independence in 2014 so that was a that
was a pretty fast turnaround through 180
180 degrees and i think as much as
anything else it was political
expediency
uh you know when they when they when
they took up the cuddles you know in
that
for that reason and then and in that way
but
you're right i mean when you you said
that about the country being divided
that
i i think referenda are
my instinct is against i think when you
when you give people
binary decisions to make you you better
have a very good reason for doing that
you know there are questions you know do
you turn around to your wife after 20
years and say
do you really love me i mean what
why would you why do you ask the
question it's not gonna
it's probably it's probably going to
cause problems asking a question
like that and the the brexit question
the scottish independence question it
was
guaranteed to cause nothing but hurt and
so it has done
hey francis do you like martians well i
work with one don't i
would you like to have an immersive
experience with a martian
are you going to get me drunk on the
vodka near my
side last time you wish no there's this
great new immersive experience in london
based on jeff wayne's
the war of the world i've heard about
this the audience reviews have been
incredible it was rated one of the top
20 things to do in london
at night and 98 of guests recommend it
the experience features a cast of 17
characters 12 live actors plus a mix of
holograms
projections and vr of west end stars
you feel all your senses fired as you
cool
slide and weave your way through 22 000
feet of immersive action including 24
extraordinary scenes and having to
escape 300-foot
martian machines and the evacuation of
london
it is fully compliant with covet
regulations and they're offering up to
10 pounds off standard weekday tickets
with our promo code which is of course
trigger
all you need to do to take advantage of
this fantastic
offer is go to the war of the worlds
immersive.com
that's the war of the worlds
immersive.com
and experience a world where we're being
invaded by martians
which is still better than being in
lockdown follow the link
in the description and i'll see you
there neil
you're a historian and i actually it
just occurred to me that that would be a
really interesting thing to talk about
and
i know you're you're very passionate
about uh scotland remaining
in within as part of the uk but give us
a historian sort of neutral observer
from a vantage point
the argument historically about scotland
being with england or not being
like what is the history of scottish and
english
uh you know coexistence if you like oh
my goodness
let me i mean before anybody else says
it you know i'm not i am not a historian
i'm an archaeologist and i love history
um and i've you know i've spent you know
i've spent 20 years
30 years you know being fascinated by
history so
i speak from that i'm an enthusiast i've
got an enthusiast's perspective rather
than
i'm not an academic historian i'll make
that i'll make that quite clear myself
um there's been something like a
scotland for a thousand years
there's been an entity understanding
itself actually first of all as alba
which is hence the you know alex salmons
breakaway independence party that he has
now
set up in competition to the to the
scottish national party
but for for over a thousand years
there's been a geographical entity
understanding itself as a place
scotland and likewise for england so
in the european context these are very
old countries
which sounds like a funny thing to say
in a way you think all countries are
probably the same age but they're not
you know there's only been germany as we
as we know it today since about 1870 to
1871
when it was unified in the form that we
recognized likewise italy
until is about the same age and other
european countries are the same age or
younger still
but so there's a great depth of history
for both
uh for both scotland and for england
uh and they and they they co-existed
you know happily and unhappily for for
even
longer than that ever since the time of
the
of the norman conquest in 1066 which was
you know was effectively a kind of a
french takeover at the boardroom level
of the united kingdom
and and thereafter that that french
norman french presence
began to have an effect not only in
england but but in scotland
as well you know robert bruce you know
the iconic
legend of scottish history and scottish
independence is robert de bruise
you know he's descended and not that far
away from
you know not not too many generations
away from from norman french
and by the time robert bruce was in play
there had been
many scottish monarchs who had imported
norman french into you know into
scotland
to be their allies and and in many ways
the wars of independence that ensued
between scotland and england
were were it was a fight between
rival french families to some extent you
edward the first
uh robert bruce there was much more
going on than anything that was just
straightforwardly traditionally
scottish in inverted commas or english
in inverted commas
and the you know they were brought they
came closer in terms of
uh marriage over over the years in the
in the 16th century margaret
tudor who was henry the eighth sister
married king james iv of scotland
so the the the english rose and the
scottish thistle
were entwined at that point in the in
the early 1500s
then in 1513 there was a catastrophic
disaster for
a scottish army that invaded england a
catastrophic scottish defeat
and and it so hollowed and and damaged
the confidence of scotland that
that given that they were already bound
by marriage it nudged scotland further
down the road towards union
when elizabeth died without an heir you
know when her long reign came to an end
she was succeeded by james vi of
scotland who became james the first of
england and so that that brought the the
two crowns together for the first time
and then in the late 17th century
scotland had got into a disastrous
overseas expedition to darien in the
panama
the narrows of panama in south america
lost a quarter of its wealth
just you know lost all in one goal it
was a catastrophic economic disaster
and in the aftermath of that scots
who had lost out hugely in that debacle
of an attempt to set up scottish
colonies in south america
were coaxed into supporting the
dissolution
of the scottish parliament and joining
together with the english parliament in
1707
to create the union of parliaments so at
that point on uh
uh scotland and england were not just
joined by a monarch but they were joined
by
a combined parliament so it's it's been
so it's been a story spanning centuries
and then
the 300 the three centuries that have
that have elapsed since that union in
1707. so scots
come to prominence scots were very
active participants
in the in what became the british empire
they were you know they were in
enthusiastic partners in everything that
the british empire did
and so more recent attempts by scots
some scots to distance themselves from
the british flag from the union jack and
from
slavery and colonialism and some and and
other aspects of british history that
have been painted very darkly in recent
times
you know as disingenuous and extreme
because scotland was always
intimately involved in all of that it
was an enthusiastic and
committed partner in all of it
and then you come down you come down to
the more recent more recent period
you know the political the political
past when i was growing up
when i was in my oh where are we now i
mean i suppose in my
my teens 20s and 30s traditionally
scotland was a country that was
dominated by labor
you know scottish scottish labour was
you know bestrode scotland like a
colossus
and it was it was always hugely
significant in terms of uk elections the
fact that
labour was always able to depend upon
this scottish bloc
vote for for labour you know it this
very influential in that in that regard
and when devolution came around in the
late 1990s
the labour party were confident that
that devolution would
would entrench their position the
scottish pa under
donald dure and the rest they saw no
reason to believe that the
labour's dominance of scotland would
ever change
but the the version of proportional
represent representation that they set
in place
the devolution settlement the scotland
act was fatally flawed
and those flaws have been exposed in
more recent times
uh and the way in which uh the you know
the snp has been able to establish
a majority of itself in the scottish
parliament is a product of the faults
that were there in the
in the scotland act and in the
devolution settlement and in the choice
of proportional representation that was
made at that time
so sorry to bore you rigid with that
you're not going to have to be a lesson
but
it's been a long it's been a long dance
it has been a long and complicated dance
you know good times bad times all the
rest of it and then you know
finally with uh you know by 2014
you know uh scotland's or some scots
sought divorce from its partner of 300
years
and now you're up to date neil let me
follow follow up a little bit on that
because
i lived in scotland from about 2000
until about 2008 2009 something like
that
and so i i saw the s p just starting to
make its first big waves
and one of the things look it's not my
fight it's not for me to decide the
future of scotland even when i lived
there but
what i did notice was a sort of strange
thing where uh
and i i i don't as i say i don't have a
particular position actually on the
independence question it's not something
i know really enough about but what i
did definitely see was
this was a time when tony blair who had
strong scottish links was prime minister
gordon brown was the scottish chancellor
of exchequer john reed was a scottish
home secretary
many of the great officers of state in
the in the united kingdom were filled by
scots
and and when one scott went he'd often
be replaced with another scar
and yet at the same time i saw this sort
of narrative about how
scottish people are underrepresented not
being given enough
influence or power that scotland is
being ignored down south
like have you noticed that as well or
did i just make that up
no no that was always that's i mean i
grew up i grew up through
through all of that in scotland it was
it was always um
it was always the case that was being
made you know through the through the
thatcher era and more recently that
um the the allegation was always made
that scotland would vote one way
and and too much of the rest of the uk
would vote for
for a conservative government and so you
know and so having voted labour
you know scots would would end up with a
with a conservative government or
or indeed you know even under you know
snp
holding sway in the scottish government
there's still a you know
for a long time has been a conservative
government in westminster but
i mean at a personal at a personal level
i can tell you that i have never
lived a single day in scotland under a
government that i voted for and i'm 54.
i've never not one not one day not one
day
have i lived under a government that
i've actually voted for so i know
for you know for different reasons than
maybe that you know that's a mainstream
but i know exactly what it feels like to
to go to the you know to go to the
polling booth every four or five years
and uh and walk away disappointed i know
what that is like but yes
that's always been the case you know
scotland scotland has a different
uh political heritage it's got you know
there's a there's a different you know
there's there's different aspects of
character for a lot of scots i mean that
is that is the case and
and the and the the devolution
settlement was supposed to create a
situation where whatever parliament was
in hollywood there wouldn't ever be an
absolute majority
the the proportion representation system
that we put in place was supposed to
mitigate against that
so that so that the whatever assembly
came together in hollywood would always
proportionally represent the many
different facets
of uh you know of scottish political
life
but that is not that is not what it
actually delivered
as has been made plain by the by the by
the way in which
you know you know nationalism is coming
increasingly to dominate every aspect of
scottish life and
scottish nationalism has always been a
minority
pursuit in scotland and when i was
growing up
you know the snp was very much a fringe
organization
it's almost a protest group uh it's so
small and inconsequential
did it tend to be in the scheme of
things but the
the devolution settlement in the the
that created the holyrood assembly had
had cracks and fissures within it and
the snp have have risen up through those
cracks like
you know like like like hot water coming
up in thermal springs and it's come out
on the surface and
and here we are with a you know with a
scotland that is dominated
disproportionately by the by the
scottish national party
and neil you were talking about the slow
dance
don't you think that scotland it's
inevitable
that you're going to do a slow dance to
uh an exit from the union i don't
believe in inevitable
i don't believe in inevitable that's the
kobayashi maroon star trek
i don't i don't believe in the
unwinnable situation
um yeah and i think anybody that looks
ahead with a crystal ball
is insane uh i don't believe the polling
how
how anyone can still be a pollster
i i do not know you know because i mean
i worked in i worked in newspapers
and i've been around polling and you
know the first thing a polling company
asks you when you approach them for a
poll is what answer do you want
you know what do you want this pool to
tell you and they'll just go away and
they'll and they'll give you that result
so all the polling that's out there now
around everything that was around brexit
that's around
support for lockdowns it's around
support for vaccine passports and all
the rest of it
all of it on account of poland and
depending on what you're looking at
you'll see that oh yeah there's been a
swing to
a vote for an increased support for for
independence or separatism in scotland
i don't buy it i talk to people
i can only really like everyone else i
can only honestly
uh reflect back the the opinions that i
hear now i'm quite i'm quite
recognizable in scotland and
you know where i live and a lot of
people come up to me and talk to me
people from all sorts of walks of life
all ages both sexes all through the
classes people come up to me and and air
their views
and my straw poll tells me that there is
still to this day a majority in favor
of remaining in the united kingdom in
scotland now that's
i can um honestly hand on heart i am
reflecting to you what i understand to
be the mood of the people in scotland
and regardless of what's said about you
know
who's going to hold majorities here
there and everywhere that's that's down
to the
that's down to the to the inadequacies
of the of the devolution settlement
i as i understand it myself based on the
people that
come up and talk to me there's a
majority in favor of remaining in the
united kingdom in scotland so in answer
to your quest you know nothing's
inevitable i don't believe in the
kobayashi meru
well that told me neil thank you very
much but
there are things that are happening in
scotland that just leave me
open mouthed the hate speech bill the
yeah is it hamza youssef who has brought
in this hate speech bill
well and forgive me i may have got this
wrong but from what i understood from
the bill
you can get arrested for things that you
say in the privacy of your own home
if it gets reported to the police well
if it it's still in the process
so the the hate crime uh bill
has gone through a consultation process
it's been approved by a vote in
in in the scottish parliament but it's
yet to get what is it the
royal assent so it's not it's not the
law of the land
yet but yes uh hypothetically
uh if i was to say something in my house
that you know sitting at the sitting on
the couch with my wife and kids
i could say something and one of my kids
could repeat it
outside in the playground at school well
if they ever go to school again
depending on who overheard what one of
my children
said i had said hypothetically i could
go to jail for seven years for something
that i said while sitting on the couch
watching telly in the privacy of my own
home
the hate crime bill has been extremely
controversial i
i don't i mean i'm not i'm not i've
never been a political person
i've never joined a political party i
hold politicians in in general
contempt really i'm cynical to the point
where
almost chokes me when i have to make a
decision about who to vote for
every general election like billy
connelly i believe the spoken desire to
be a politician should bar you for life
from other being allowed to be one
that said i've i've drifted into paying
more and more attention to things
political as the years have gone on
i only became aware of a hate crime bill
in truth because i realized that so many
unlikely bed fellows
were getting together to say this is a
disaster waiting to happen
you know it was figures from the church
it was the police
it was people from the legal fraternity
uh it was
authors comedians
politicians all sorts of people were
coming together
you know this this unlikely confederacy
formed when it was
in the consultation period seeing you
there's holes in this this legislation
is so sloppy
so loose so open to dangerous
misinterpretation it's a disaster
waiting to
happen a lot of the disquiet
rotates around the notion of stirring up
hatred
that's that's the language that's
involved if you
if you say something or do something and
someone who hears you say it
believes in their heart that you were
stirring up hatred
then potentially you're in trouble and
the onus would be on you
to prove that you had not intended to
stir up that hatred
and i it might have passed me by but so
many
different groups people that you would
never have expected to hear speaking
together on the same subject
were saying you can't have that the the
notion that you might stir up hatred
it's
it's so vague you could drive a coaching
horses through the gaps in it
tighten that up or take it out all
together and so i thought
goodness me there truly must be
something questionable about this
and you know there's been various
amendments made and things taken out but
in the form that it went through for
approval by
the scottish bank which it got everyone
voted for it with the exception of the
conservative msps
snp labour lib them in green they all
nodded it through
it was shameful that they've voted
through this
flawed dangerously untidy sloppy
legislation
uh and we'll see what we'll see what
becomes of it in the years ahead
but yes you know hypothetically the
the danger that it poses to freedom of
speech freedom of expression
uh is is alive and well in scotland and
we're all worried sick about it
hey kkk do you like feeling silky and
smooth
like a sexual dolphin never talk to me
again
what if i told you that manscaped have
brought out a new and improved lawnmower
3.0
that allows you to be fresh and trim for
the ladies
down below i've been married 20 years
the last time i was fresh and trimmed
down below
jimmy savile was a respected children's
entertainer i'm going to ignore that the
lawnmower has a cutting edge ceramic
blade
which reduces the risk of having an
accident where you least want an
accident
my bank account no you idiot you know
los werbus oh right plus it's waterproof
which means you can groom in the shower
and it has an
led light so you can get a really
accurate and precise trim excellent
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to manscape.com and you'll get
20
off with free shipping just use our code
which is of course
trigger that's 20 off with free shipping
at
manscape.com and use our code trigger
your werewolf well thank you excellent
neil i've gigged many times in scotland
i've gigged in the standing glasgow many
times
going to be honest with you it's my
favorite comedy club in the uk
brilliant the crowds are amazing you
know you're much freer than you would be
in shishi liberal london where everybody
takes offense and grabs their handbag
you know because you start to go into
you know choppier waters
how can it be that a land like that
where there's a love of jokes there's a
love of banter that has produced
incredible comedians transgressive
comedians people
associate billy colony now as being this
cute cuddly comedian
he wasn't in his pomp jerry sadowitz
why have you suddenly gone down this
route well
that is the question that everyone on my
side of the debate
once answered it was always i mean there
were
so many reasons when i when i would when
i would go
on holiday in my teens you know when i
was a student and
and shortly thereafter i'd be whatever
i'd been the greek islands or
spain or whatever it was always it was
always a joy to be identified as
somebody from scotland
because it as soon as people realized
people from all over all over europe
they associated
from scotland and they they expected you
to be funny
and they expected that right off the top
they could uh you know they could uh
they could um take the pee out of you
and you know they could have they would
expect to be able to have great fun with
you
that you wouldn't take offense that you
were up for a laugh it was all
it was and we were we were regarded as
being sort of free thinking
open uh you know liberal tolerant people
and it was
it was a joy it was a joy to be
associated with that
and i have lived to see scotland go
through this metamorphosis
where now there's this puritanism has
come through there's always puritan
aspects to scotland you know
pure scotland was one of the few
countries in europe that took calvinism
to its breast
you know while other countries in europe
were saying you know over my dead body
there's
there's always been that element in that
joylessness
it's part of the gate of the nation it's
part of the rich tapestry that is
scotland but there were always
these small minded calvinist joyless
you know just you know go home and live
in your miserable wee house and drink a
cup of tea and
and watch a soap opera on the telly and
that's good enough for you there was
always that element but it was drowned
out
by the by the broader picture of scots
who were you know who were ready for a
joke ready for a laugh didn't take
things too seriously
you know were passionate about a
discussion passionate politically
enjoyed nothing more than having a right
good square go of a debate in a pub or
over a dinner table or whatever and then
would just move on from it and then
five days later have the same fight
again and you know
and and just go through it all again and
now
with the with the hate crime bill and
other legislation there is just this
sense
of of of the scottish government of the
scottish national party
wanting to put a lid on what has always
been scotland
shut the door draw the curtains keep
yourself to yourself
be secretive you know there's just this
um
claustrophobic joyless
atmosphere that has that has established
itself like
damp in scotland and it's dispiriting in
the extreme and yes you're absolutely
right
for no it was no surprise that say the
the edinburgh fringe
you know was regarded around the world
as as somewhere that you'd come to to
see
or to listen to the best fun comedy on
the planet
and now a situation has been created
where somebody's seeing
something that could be construed as
stirring up hatred
like god knows i mean how many how many
different ways could you interpret a
statement like that
could see a could see a comedian end up
in jail
that's why i've been encouraging him to
go back to scotland so i can have the
podcast to myself
well you joke but actually neil you know
uh
the last time we were able to do
edinburgh as comedians was 2019
i took my show to edinburgh and as part
of the show i made a number of
you know it was a show about the
importance of freedom of expression and
so i deliberately went out of my way
to show that certain very offensive
words can be uttered in in a particular
context and i would have jokes
to to to support that and to take the
the the audience on a journey
from well i'm not sure freedom of speech
is important all the way to well here's
some examples and here's how you go with
it but
in order to do that i had to bring up
very offensive things
and to talk about them comedically now
i'll be honest with you
if i was doing that show now i would not
come back to the edinburgh fringe
well no you'd well we're yet to see
we're yet to see as i say that
as under the heat the criminal's not
there yet but that was one of the
loudest groups that spoke out
in consternation and alarm when this
thing was going through its consultation
period were comedians that was one of
the things that was grabbing headlines
the length and breadth of
of the uk with comedians saying i'll
never be able to go back to edinburgh
i can't go and do i can't go and do a
you know such and such
a show because i could end up in jail
and it'd even be it wouldn't you
wouldn't even have to say it in
in in scotland i mean i've you know i've
been doing stuff on
you know i've been doing stuff on you
know i just i talked to talk radio on a
weekly basis
you know that that gets broadcast
nationally and you know
hypothetically mike graham or another of
the
another of the djs could could find
themselves accused of stirring up hatred
in scotland
although they're taking part in a
broadcast from london
the the the sloppy nature
of the legislation that has gone through
frightens everyone to death and for
someone
you know like me i mean i i i
revel although i've never been political
i
revel in arguing i love arguing with
people
and i love you know i would take up a
position
on a on a topic just so that i could
have a fight about it
i don't mean fisticuffs i just mean a
verbal exchange
because that's in it's in my nature to
do that and to
you know to express opinions and i love
being i love being
in the cut and thrust of all that you
know heated debate
and all the rest of it and and that that
the opportunity
to have something as simple and joyful
as a heated argument
about a topic about whatever gender or
race or religion or all the stuff of
life
but you couldn't have that debate in
scotland from now on because
you could open your mouth be accused of
stirring up hatred and be in berlin
for seven years berlin prison in glasgow
oh i'm well familiar with it no
but neil i it's it's an interesting
moment we're in
because i feel like scotland
yet yeah i feel like scotland is not
really an exception on this front you
you have some stuff going on that maybe
we don't quite yet but broadly
we seem to be in a very particular
moment in history where
we are repeating a lot of the mistakes
that have been repeated
at these peak moments of madness in the
past what what
how do you look at it from an you know
obviously an archaeologist but an
enthusiastic history like what is the
moment we're in
what are some of the parallels what
should we be wary of as societies in the
current climate
i think well it can only be a it can
only be cumulative
it can't it must be a it must be a
cocktail of many elements
i think in no small part it has to do
with the fact that
you know broadly since broadly speaking
since the end of the second world war
the people of western europe and
certainly this
archipelago have broadly lived in peace
you know and and that and that that
threat has been has
has been something that happened
elsewhere and and and i suspect with
that comes
a dangerous complacency and
and we've we've lived with and we've
enjoyed
freedoms that are that are unique not
just in the world but unique in history
as as many people have said you know
life has been almost intolerable for 99
of the human species for 99 of the time
uh and what what what evolved very very
recently in our part of the world
was unique uh and so vulnerable
uh and if if too many i suppose if too
many generations go by
without the the necessity to
defend and and be aware of the
uniqueness of our position
i suppose it it it's too easy to grow up
thinking that that which is here now
will always be here
as though tolerance and freedom and the
ability to travel around and do what you
like and say what you like and travel
internationally
um and and take all advantage of all of
those freedoms
you you might think that they're natural
but they're not nothing about the way
that we've lived in our part of the
world for 100 years
has been natural it's extremely
unnatural
it's blessed and been wonderful
but it's an incredibly fragile flower
and
it's only when that when that when that
beautiful thing is snatched away from
people that they realize that the
snatching away is even possible
i don't think it occurs to people you
know we live we live in something that
is held aloft by
by by centuries of of hard-won
struggle you know we're in a penthouse
flat with a fantastic view
and the the ossified desiccated bones
that are holding us up
are made and shaped by the suffering of
generation after generation
and it's a it's been a story of triumph
and disaster
but it's left us held up somewhere in
the sky
and if you knock out if you knock out
those layers below us that tower that's
been holding us up we will not remain
suspended in mid-air
you know our our lovely penthouse with
its fantastic views of the world will
just topple
it'll just drop straight to the ground
and there's maybe we're two three
generations into
soft living maybe all i mean i
i caught the the end of of that of those
generations that were let loose
as a kid i was just sent out the house
in the morning and
and came back in at night or when i got
hungry um
but but but the generation's sins and
and i've seen it with my own children
wrapped in cotton wool you know looked
after
a a you know as though they were fine
bone china that was going to be you know
terribly damaged if anybody handled it
roughly
and and i think those generations maybe
a couple of generations have come up
risk averse
um and feeling threat everywhere
and that the advent of something like
this you know pandemic
uh has just been the has just been
something that has
that has terrified people and made
people think that maybe the world isn't
a perfect place
and in seeking safety from it they've
been prepared to surrender
we are too many people have been
prepared to surrender well
all of the freedom in order to feel safe
from a virus that's 99.7
survivable anyway and look how quickly
look how quickly society changes you
know you might have thought five years
ago you might have said that changes
like we've gone through in the last 12
months would take
a generation now you do it in a weekend
if you're busy enough
and here we are i mean here we are in
indeed neil and i suppose the question
is how do we roll back from this
because it seems we're hitting crisis
point in scotland in england
all over the world do you think there
might be a natural backlash against
everything that's happening neil just a
younger generation of people coming
through who are like
well we've been brought up with safety
we need to rebel against it we want
freedom again
uh and and we've got a generation maybe
of younger people this is just me
talking optimistically now which is
unusual for me uh
you know talking thinking about well
we've got an opportunity now to be
different we want to rebel against our
parents
we want freedom we want to be able to
say what we think
we want to be able to do what we want to
do well i think
you're right i think it's an obligation
to be optimistic
uh almost i mean i'm as depressive as
the next
as the next celtic scot you know i've
got i tend towards the dark side
all the time and my and my wife says to
me all the time
you know you know lighten up for god's
sake
[Laughter]
because i i tend i tend to the darkness
and
and and i i do feel that it's it's
almost an obligation
to to to hope for the best
and i would like to think you know i've
got i've got kids uh
17 15 and 12 and you know we talk to
them
and i know that they have unconsciously
absorbed
the the the appreciation of the
of the freedoms that we've had you know
we've had the kids traveling a bit and
they've you know they
go to school and they do the normal
things you know they've lived in a you
know they've lived in a free society
where they were able to you know roam
around and go to cinema and go out to
eat and see the friends and stay in each
other's houses and all the rest of it
and they've seen that they've seen that
taken away and they ball catch it i see
them bridle at it
and they tell us that their friends
their their peers their contemporaries
are saying the same and and so that
you hope you hope you absolutely hope
that some of that appetite for freedom
has become genetic or epigenetic and
that and it's there in people's dna
and ultimately everything's always about
the people
it's it's so simplistic and cliched to
say it
but the those making decisions and those
those who seek to rule over us are
a microscopic minority
and you've got you know in every country
you've got tens of millions of people
uh and if and if tens of millions of
people are dissatisfied
and exercise their uh right
to to to live freely uh then
you know then that that will prevail you
know that that
you know freedoms have been taken from
people wholesale before but
but the desire for freedom is like is
like grass through tarmac
it just comes back and and it takes so
much energy for authoritarian and
totalitarian regimes to keep the
pressure on
that inevitably they always become
exhausted
it takes too much effort i mean we all
know that you know
if you're going to have a police state
you end up in a situation where you need
one policeman for every person
at least and it becomes too exhausting
and it's it's easier it's easier to be
free
and and i hope i hope that that people
you know realize it's all about looking
at what we've had
and knowing that it's as fragile as a
spring flower
you know uh a moment you know as
as robert burton said you know like the
snow falls in the river
a moment white then melts forever you
know it's
these these freedoms that we have had
are
are fragile and ethereal he seized the
flower it's bloom is dead you know
if if enough people waken up to the fact
that
you know freedoms are are are fragile
uh rare and and to and to be cherished
and
and
yes the obligation is to be optimistic
and and the obligation is to hope that
uh the enough people demand uh
the freedom that they have known neil
thank you so much for that it was been
an absolutely brilliant
interview flew by um we always finish
our interviews with the same question
which is what is a one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
the truth i keep hearing
i keep hearing most recently on that
royal interview
about people talking about my truth your
truth
there's only the truth and
enough everything everything the kind of
society that i
want and the kind of society that that i
know that the majority of the people
that i know and love
want is predicated upon
everyone having the confidence and
indeed taking
the responsibility accepting the
obligation to
tell the truth don't just think it
don't just know it but every opportunity
you get in a public forum
tell the truth it's like mark twain said
if you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
neil thank you so much for coming on the
show it's been an
absolutely brilliant episode as it
always is with you
if you want to find neil on twitter go
to the coast guy and you'll be able to
find him there
you can also check him out on patreon if
you can spare
a little don't make sure you do because
neil's work is
absolutely brilliant and he has a
brilliant podcast out as well he's one
of the best people at talking about
history
so make sure you check that out thank
you for watching and we will see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or live stream
take care and we'll see you soon take
care and remember they go out
always seven o'clock uk time see you
soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below